we have unfinished business black widow
is back the first trailer for the solo
black widow movie has dropped finally so
let's take a look at how Black Widow
could set up the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right now on the
kitchen the santalune Black Widow movie
is next on marvelously and it comes out
on may 1st of 2020 and with the Infinity
Saga behind us
this film officially kicks off phase 4
in the MCU and if you're like this
Twitter user you could be wondering
didn't she die in endgame Marvel's
timeline can be confusing man we have to
go back to where it all started well
Black Widow will take place after the
events of Captain America Civil War and
before Avengers infinity war where
Natasha Romanoff finds herself on the
run and confronting her past and judging
by the looks of the trailer it looks
like a lot of the action takes place in
Budapest so does this mean Hawkeye could
be in this movie maybe you and I
remember Budapest very definite and
speaking of action the new trailer gave
us a ton snow action flying through air
action and even some motorcycle footage
which always leads to more action and we
also got a good look at a bunch of other
new characters in the trailer including
David Harbor and that had more than a
few people on Twitter saying things like
so did the Black Widow teaser just
confirmed that chief hopper is in Russia
valid question my friend but we can
confirm that in this movie harbor is
actually rent guardian and who better to
tell us about Red Guardian than David
himself this Russians name is Alexei of
szostak off and he he is the red
Guardian who's the counterpart to
Captain America again and he's also got
a tremendous history with Natasha
Romanoff Black Widow
maybe they've known each other for a
long time
and it seems as though this is the year
of the PUE because we also got a good
look at Florence view as Yelena Bulova
another recruit of the Black Widow
program and clearly a sister figure to
Natasha and we also met Melina a
seasoned Black Widow played by Rachel
Weisz those intros along with footage
that appears to show the red-room
training facility and even more black
widows could be setting the stage for
ScarJo to pass the torch to a new Black
Widow for phase 4 including the upcoming
Marvel TV shows on Disney Plus because
you know ScarJo as Black Widow is dead
now that is not a spoiler and game was
the highest-grossing film of all time
forever and the trailer also gave us a
first glimpse at the villain taskmaster
so in the comics taskmaster is an
assassin for hire who possesses the
ability to mimic anything he sees so
he's taken on the fighting styles of
countless Marvel heroes and while the
rumors of an Iron Man appearance in the
movie will have to stay in the rumor
mill we did get an appearance of
fattiest Thunderbolt Ross played by
William Hurt now he's seen as a younger
man than he would have been in the time
of Civil War so it looks like flashbacks
will be happening but also Iron Man is
alive so let's get that campy out what
so while the MCU seems to be going
backwards in order to move forward with
Facebook fans are just as excited for
more Marvel except of course those who
just want more video 'no but hey with
everyone in the second Disney family you
just never know one thing's for sure
gonna be a hell of a reunion alright
friends it's time to kick it over to you
now are you excited for this new Black
Widow movie and what do you hope to see
in it aside from baby Yoda also do we
think chief hopper is officially in
Russia now let us know all your thoughts
and feelings in the comment section and
for more Marvel news head on over to
Rotten Tomatoes comm and guess what our
first book rotten movies we love is out
right now it celebrates 101 movies that
are coming in green but definitely worth
checking out anyway as always thanks for
watching the ketchup if you liked this
episode and you want to see more we know
you do subscribe and click that Bell
icon I'm NASA Prez and we'll see you
guys next time
[Music]